It's been way too long the smartest Rick
and Mortiest Morty in the universe are back
and things are pretty much the same
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Rick and Morty season
4 trailer video for the rest of the
episodes for season 4 that's right
episodes 6 through 10 it might be April
1st but this is not an April Fool's Day
Rick and Morty joke so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Rick and Morty videos we'll do a
giveaway for Rick and Morty merch all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your biggest
Citadel of Rick's evil Morty theory on
the video because the Citadel is heavily
featured during all this footage we'll
just go through all the Easter eggs and
references here shot by shot we even get
a new scene from an episode that
confirms another real scene from the
season 4 intro but it looks like utter
chaos and war in all the different
episodes that they go to there are
several large battles that they fight in
they're either running from creatures or
running to fight creatures so if you
felt like there wasn't enough action in
the first half of season 4 it seems like
they just completely ramped it up in the
back half like they're saving all the
really good stuff for the second half of
the season and it seems like they're
bringing back a ton of old characters
that we have not seen in a long long
time so get a shout-out for Phoenix
person we just got that big Toonami
anime episode that they did a couple of
days ago I've already done a video for
that so I'll link it at the end of this
but in another big anime reference at
the beginning of the trailer here Rick
calls out the anime trope of overly long
suit up montages now I saw a lot of
people questioning what this is
specifically referencing but it looks
mostly like it's meant to be a Gundam
Wing Morty and Gundam Wing Rick
reference so no surprise that they just
did a big long anime episode but it also
reminds you of Jerry at the beginning of
season 4 where he was yelling at Rick
for Morty turning himself into an Akira
saying no more anime stuff but the
aliens that they're fighting are
actually from Rick and Morty season 3
episode 5 were leader Lee conspiracy
with the really wide eyes but the aliens
that they're fighting seems like they've
been taken over by this weird facehugger
species that are then later trying to
get inside Rick's ship so it's really
the facehuggers that they're fighting
and it seems like summer has seemingly
become their queen like they're all
fawning over her
some reason and she's wearing their
clothing Rick tells Morty that they had
to wear the Dead face hookers in order
to blend in and oops Morty's is still
alive another great example of how Rick
does care about Morty but doesn't really
care about their physical forms so much
like he's replaced his body's so many
times season 3 episode 1 is a great
example of him just jumping from body to
body not really caring about his body
being destroyed he's only a little more
careful with Morty but not that precious
with Morty's body like later in the
trailer when he says if anything goes
wrong which it won't be sure to jump
into the same vat of acid that I do you
have this giant army of the Rick's from
the Citadel of Rick's in battle armor
standing in formation with an army of
meeseeks and then it's a little too
pixelated to make out this other Legion
of giant creatures but they kind of look
familiar to all getting ready to lay
siege to this walled city their armor
gives off a very Doctor Who Time Lords
vibe a long time ago Dan Harmon
reference Doctor Who is one of the
bigger inspirations for how Rick and
Morty works even though they try to
avoid time travel with very few
exceptions season 4 episode 5 is a
really good example that with the snake
Terminator plot which seems kind of
counter to their policies before so
there's a little bit of time travel in
Rick and Morty now they pick up with
Thin Lizzy's the boys are back in town
theme song which is just a reference to
the show coming back but you could also
think of it as a meta reference to all
the other versions of Rick and Morty
being back like the Citadel of Rick's as
we see which also means that evil Morty
is also back dan and Justin did say at
the beginning of season 4 that there
would be a big Rick and Morty season 5
teaser in a season 4 post credits scene
I'm just assuming that there's probably
going to be the season 4 finale and
it'll have something to do with their
serialized evil Morty Citadel Ark this
is a scene of Rick running through a
different building somewhere else
shooting at these robotic looking
creatures firing a turd atom with green
looking portal fluid powering it but
it's probably not portal fluid it's
probably just a coincidence that it's
green because this doesn't look like
Citadel architecture or design language
in the portal fluid is heavily regulated
in a closely guarded secret by all
Rick's not just the Citadel of Rick's
the whole basis for a couple of story
arcs in the beginning was the Galactic
government trying to get his portal
technology as well as other races
wanting to get his portal fluid he
drinks a flask a blue fluid which gives
him five arms almost making him like
Spider Man during the six arm saga you
can
to make a general grievous Star Wars
joke - Rick battles a giant wolf in some
snowbound ice city it's a little hard to
make out what kind of aliens those ice
statues are made to resemble but then
Rick looks like he's trying to perform
some sort of exorcism on Morty removing
some aspect that's bound to him holding
this remote maybe this is something that
Morty did to himself on accident because
Rick has that look on his face that he
gets when Morty does something stupid
and he has to clean up the mess there's
a really cool transition to a different
scene in a different episode of them
fighting in this giant be like hive
structure that's overtaking this city
this might have something to do with the
summer facehugger plot you get a clear
shot of the cars battery an engine
compartment when Morty is using the
underside turret which one it's cool
that Rick ship has a turret gun Star
Wars Millennium Falcon style but it also
reminds you that zip Zam floorp is still
alive down in the battery even though I
think technically time is supposed to
move faster down there
speaking of big characters coming back
snuffles is back from Rick and Morty
season 1 episode 2 lawnmower dog and it
looks like he's in a battle to the death
with some sort of hyper intelligent cat
race and they're just battling each
other in their mechs I'm assuming this
is some Dan Harmon cats hating dogs joke
that he's riffing on here when Rick
pulls up the garage door here and the
SWAT trucks arrive he's also got that
nonchalant look on his face like he's in
the middle of explaining why Morty is
stupid for wanting to do something and
before he can finish his sentence
something stupid happens it's hard to
tell where Jerry is here but there are
so many scenes of them referencing the
Citadel this might be where Jerry is
flying through these transport tubes but
he's got a camping pack with him in a
bedroll so they might open the episode
which is like the basic premise that
they're on a camping trip that just goes
completely off the rails this is Morty
being chased down by Rick cops from the
Citadel of Rick's after it looks like he
busts out of one of these incubators
that you see in the background meaning
that they do go back to the Citadel at
some point or this Morty bite just be
one of the many Morty replacements they
always reference one free replacement
Morty voucher then they finally bring
back Jessica so I'm assuming that
Phoenix person is somewhere nearby here
in this big battle that they're fighting
but she and some are having a big
lightsaber battle to the death nice Star
Wars reference there's a statue of what
looks like a dog behind them so this
larger battle that there
engaged in might have something to do
with what's going on with snuffles in
this giant cat bite and because the end
of season 3 episode 1 implied that
jessica has some crazy Authority maybe
this is just the Galactic government
remnants trying to come back or maybe
they're trying to make some reference to
the new Star Wars films with the first
order this is a scene confirming one
more real scene during the new season
for intro it's always fun to try and
guess which is the intro scenes are
actually showing up in episodes during a
season normally you would say some of
them are real scenes some of them are
fake scenes but I also like the theory
that all the intro scenes are meant to
be real it's just that they haven't got
to all those episodes yet like the
long-running baby Cthulhu episode theory
but this guy here that looks kind of
ridiculous
seems like you something right out of
Flash Gordon based on the design of
these green vats it seems like they're
falling into portal fluid just because
this green swirling motion is exactly
the way the portals look so it might be
happening back at the Citadel but you
could also make a Batman Joker origin
story reference like the Joker falls
into the VAT of acid and becomes the
Joker this joke about Jerry's own honey
seems like a Newman's Own reference if
you're not familiar with that Paul
Newman the actor has a line of food
products called Newman's Own so it seems
like Jerry's tried to create his own
brand of honey the honey might be
related to the scenes of Rick and Morty
fighting on that'd be like world with
the bee like ships to love the way the
family just casually shades him when he
yells about having dreams and
aspirations like they don't even take
him seriously not even a little bit just
casually resuming their conversation is
that they didn't hear him it kind of
brings things back around from the
beginning of the season where he got all
high and mighty with Rick when he was
trying to go off with more during that
first adventure then Rick isn't quite
sure if he's taking the right amount of
adderall just reminding you that he is
on the spectrum I think the first time
he openly implied that he had some form
of autism was when they were playing
Minecraft in season 3 episode 10 right
before the president called them but if
he didn't see it during the trailer the
episodes are coming back May 3rd and
they'll be 5 more episodes so 10
episodes total during season 4 I'm
assuming it's going to be the same for the
rest of the 70 episodes of Rick and
Morty hopefully they won't do the same
thing with season 5 breaking it in half
so we only get 5 & 5 but they might wind
up doing the same thing at the end of
this year where they air the first half
of season 5 and then they wait till the
middle of next year to air the second
half of season 5 but at least
we have a better idea for how they
structure the seasons I know everyone
wants to know why they did this in the
first place why did they wait so long to
air the second five episodes it's
actually because they blew past their
deadlines they even said it during a
clip earlier this year when they were
trying to promote the first half of the
season we had all ten ready to go but we
had to legally cut it back to just five
we did some focus test screenings we
showed all 10 episodes to a housewife
from Salt Lake City and her balls blew
off like after episode three Rick and
Morty could actually literally blow your
balls off I missed all of our deadlines
when Rick and Morty came back for season
four the network actually appointed a
special executive producer that Dan
Harmon said in his words was there to
keep the trains running on time but I
don't know when he came on board even
though there are a lot of delays
happening right now because of what's
going on with the virus around the world
animation it's a little bit easier to
complete from home so now that they have
the ball rolling even worst case
scenario they break the seasons in half
they'll still be able to get them out on
a more regular basis so you might go six
months without episodes instead of going
a full two years without episodes again
if he spotted any big easter eggs in the
trailer that I didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the
comments and I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post new Rick and Morty there
will be some more promos before the
season actually gets here so just a bit
of good news with all the bad stuff
that's happening around the world right
now
everyone click here to watch that anime
Rick and Morty episode and click here
for my brand new venom 2 spider-man
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!